welcome to this blitz game against
attention master artists yeah art or pin
yet sick okay from Poland ok maybe the
classical again I scored pretty well
with that I think in the blitz games c5
now this is probably popular and Poland
because um it has been played by some
top polish players like Josh go and okay
looking a name him sasha cohen Asiata
probably totally butchering the
pronunciation I'm sorry okay so does our
budget it seems that he's trying to get
two more like a hand had shock yeah had
almost the same the same thing in an
earlier game oh wait an ID for have to
be a bit careful but I have the sugar
for him yeah whenever the croissants is
that we have to think about those those
honey trixia 94 with possible bishop at
three twin age to mating stuff but it's
not working at all the am not at all the
at-6 looks normal but it seems he yeah I
can't now he's doing it how am I going
to play this
mm-hmm I wonder maybe still a Bishop f4
set up putting pressure on the on the
pawn Bishop f4 it's got 95 to you for
all the time hmm it's always difficult
to trying to get something against the
head shock this intends to put the
bishop on g3 putting pressure on the
porn from there okay so i can play
something very straightforward like rock
d to look T one but he's covering that
covering that pretty easily and he has
got 95 possibly okay however I wonder if
he can play no behaves not possible
yeah doubling on the D ha I don't really
know if this is this is leading to
anything okay sometimes you can take on
f3 at the moment that's not an issue but
sometimes it can write difficult
difficult to find a plan against the
Hedgehog as usual I just want to play
Queen B 1 get it out of the sea file and
then go from them Bishop f3 I can take
with the bishop simply Quincy for bit
should be to getting a six pack okay it
seems that he wants to go for 94 okay I
can play 92 what I want it's not very
active right this last night be three
yeah a lot at all easy black is pretty
okay maybe I have to play with before
ultimately and pushes night back it's
something that you very often a little
bit reluctant to play as wide as c4 is
very very weakened yeah under half open
see how but maybe you cannot do without
it the meat meat on g2
she tried to play 94 just trading
everything off no the step one that I
did not expect at all interesting okay
let's say I go before before nineties
then I go Quinn be one method sets a
pretty pretty bad setup for black isn't
it okay I'm curious I mean 94 should
definitely be okay for me at least okay
and 97 I just moved the Queen on the
side and then his queen is right in the
sea fowl with looks which looks really
in really bad where do i go to be one or
two be to know okay let's let's move
that and now I mean here I'm threatening
cd5 and night discoveries and takes on
c4 night c4 looks really really ugly but
maybe it's not so bad I don't know on
the sea huh no d5 really surprised me I
think it was totally okay before that
now I'm not so sure
now the Queen also doesn't have many
squares you know even be five even be
five is a move sometimes like b5 takes
Knight takes threatens night a7 and the
queen is almost trapped plus a fork so
there are some some concrete threats now
of course also just taking on d5 is a is
a threat Bishop on G to know is also
strong piece at d5 was this was a bad
decision ok so at least this who what
sets Teague's hmm how to say what's best
now it it looks very nice for wide sea
takes Knight eggs
okay I cannot calculate it so quickly
what what the best best continuation is
Teague's I guess yeah i mean this is
this is what i have would I this is good
I don't know if it was the best
continuation his Queen has to move now
and I have worked his seven Knight b6 at
the end maybe I was something better but
this is a certainty and certainly a good
one so look d7 look-see for this time
morning yeah I know I know
so let's see how am I going to play here
Queenie for a problem putting this
pressure only five and getting Bishop c4
in for the the most activity possible
and he cannot play f6 of the sling for
Bishop c4
okay i'm slightly head on the clock that
said sir good and they don't have a huge
problem on this in this way Bishop a six
how does he prevent that now probably
not at all okay this this one there's no
tactic here might know but should be
self what did I overlooked something and
he's so shocked that I didn't play the
move I don't know okay maybe something
happened on his end that needed
attention okay I hope I'm not
disconnected sometimes nope I'm not
disconnected or what he has a somewhat
shaky connection and cannot be he's he
just this is a really a disconnection
issue not a voluntary one year like
those kind of people who disconnected
instead of resigning it's just that he
has an internet problem yeah the double
Bishop endgame here is very black
perfect due to this connection yeah okay
it wasn't his his we didn't do this on
purpose yeah this is of course um yeah
this is winning for white Bishop takes
I'm going here the idea is like a form i
can put the bishop over and then move
the king this is a win now with the two
bishops and the extra pony
okay so if we go back I think he had a
totally fine position until he ventured
this d5 yes he's completely fine he can
even play night to e4 which is some kind
of fitting to what he did earlier um
yeah and here is equal home I mean I can
do do all those trades here but now we
see that I have a hard time to put more
pressure on this pawn and here he's
probably pretty um no okay it's not so
easy I was thinking he can play d 5 in
some moment anyway but this is not so
easy in any case he has no problems
whatsoever because I don't get big
pressure on this pawn anywhere this is a
regrouping for the bishop and I probably
don't even not even getting to a
doubling on the deef also the the
capture only four years is giving me
nothing but what else do I have here not
much yeah I don't know I didn't find a
great way to play against the head shop
here it was a pretty pretty solid set up
after d hi forever it looks it looks
tricky before yeah the computer gives
night c2e form and says that this is
still just a slight edge for white
that's maybe true i mean this this is
something that he oops that he that he
must do it's nothing that he is his girl
is glad to do but he can play this
position getting out of the sefa and
then we just continue it looks like why
does some a little bit like white is a
pawn abia but it's not so easy he can
sometimes one ideas sometimes like f6
and maybe he 5 at the right moment that
makes my bishop look rather silly he's
got this this pawn on e4 which a little
bit obstructs my position why does
certainly a little bit better here but
it's nothing nothing
but after that I have a hard time to
believe the position will be one okay
the computer says night h phi f is no
and now it now it there now the
evaluation goes up and up and up ok so
my hunch wasn't wasn't wrong yeah ok the
computer gives us the best line the
capture on d4 and see if I'm sorry it
takes and then e 5 which is yeah okay if
you have to play that things are not not
going well you just jettisons a pawn to
get to get a square for the Queen yeah
so what is basically winning upon yeah
I'm curious if this was what I played if
this was the right continuation here the
computer agrees it wants to play in the
same manner takes Bishop Bishop takes is
of course more active for wider and rook
takes and 94 and okay so then this was
this was a decent play what I what I did
when you force the best move push 56
that's all normal okay yeah I overlooked
something instead of Queen a8 I can take
immediately okay yeah forum for this for
this tactic this is even better I only
saw that this is either winning the pawn
or forcing the Queen trade and the Queen
trade is a winning end game however
Bishop 86 is of course stronger yeah
okay hope you like this thanks for
watching